One of the unique features of mobile applications is site recognition.
Mobile users take their devices everywhere
Adding site awareness to your app gives users a more engaging experience.
My name is Colt McCannless,
While this attractive location data makes your app more useful,
, Abuse can cost you a lot with respect to battery life.
Now, the standard site request seems like something like this.
On behalf of performance,
Let's take a look at the first two values, the two API intervals.
SetInterval sets the rate in milliseconds
Where your app prefers to receive site updates.
The lower the number, the more updates you get,
Of course the more you consume the battery as a result,
Which means finding the right value to use as a time interval is an important balance.
If it is too fast, a lot of battery will be consumed for GPS requests.
If it's too slow, your app will not update quickly enough to be useful to the user.
Eventually you want to reach the state
So you can be more dynamic in terms of how you interact with this device.
For example, if you notice that the site has stayed the same for a while,
There is a high probability that the user will be fixed for a long time.
So try to reduce the sampling interval in order to reduce battery depletion
Resulting from this process.
But it should also be noted that other applications
Also affects the rate of updates sent to your app.
In fact, the platform will send updates at a faster rate
Of any application requests updates with the Setinterval API
Across the entire system,
This means that your app can eventually receive site events
Faster than the required frequency of your application,
It may flood you with a torrent of site information
It does a lot of other things that you do not really need to do.
This is why the SetFastestInterval API is used.
Basically, this lets you minimize
The frequency at which you receive updates that you may not be interested in or are ready for.
So that your application does not waste time updating and processing site events
When it is not needed.
Now let's take a look at setPriority.
You have to remember that the prevailing way that your computer analyzes its physical location on Earth
Are assisted by GPS devices.
Basically, there is a series of satellites flying high outside the Earth's atmosphere
Whose function is to deliver topical information to your device
Based on your movements.
Simply put, the GPS device in your phone
Exchange signals between satellite and data tower
To determine your position in space and time,
Which as you imagine, is a very intense process on the battery.
But this is not the only way you can get your site data.
In addition to GPS expensive, there is also a network provider,
Which determines the location based on the availability of the cellular tower and Wi-Fi access points.
The result will provide you with less accurate results,
But it uses only part of the battery compared to the GPS version.
Of course, there is an anonymous provider, which is probably the most effective for the battery.
When some other applications request the site,
Results will also move through your app.
This way your device does not send multiple queries to the site
It can save battery for longer time.
Now, in order to make all this accessible to the API needs of the site,
You can control the types of networks and battery consumption you want
Using the setPriority option to request the location.
If you are already using an activity ID
To determine what device or application it is or when it is not being used,
You can take advantage of this data to turn off the site inquiry request
Or you can reduce it when it is not needed.
But in fact, the balance and gain for each API depends on the situation
The process is indeed cumbersome,
Which is why Android has made it much easier.
By using the FusedLocationProvider API,
Where you get a simplified interface for all this madness,
Android will deal with all the chaotic details on your behalf,
Saving you both battery as well as sanity based on code.
Now, if you are puzzled about how the battery is consumed,
Always make sure to take a closer look at the dated battery tool.
It will gladly remind you of all the things you do wrong
And give you hints on how to fix it.
So as not to waste in the world of battery performance.
Check out the rest of the video clips of Android performance patterns
Join our Google+ forum to ask questions to great performance experts.
So stay calm, type your code, and always remember, performance is important.